the prophet
sallam tells us in narration in
a that no Arab holds an inherent virtue
over a
non-arab nor any non-arab over an Arab
no white over a black nor any black over
a
white true virtue is in
piety all of you originate from Adam and
Adam originates from dust from
dirt
however being that things are have
escalated to a degree I don't believe
any of us really
expected and
that it is extremely widespread
everyone can see it can watch it in real
time and you know nothing is is
really being done about it with
regards to stopping this
transgression or any other countes
intervening and so forth this is
terrible but it's not
unexpected if a person were to
expect
that any of the surrounding Arab
countries or any of the foreign
countries even less so were going to
intervene and put a stop to something
this that is a very far-fetched
idea it's not something that is
unexpected
unfortunately and the prophet sallallah
alai wasam told us 1500 years ago of
many of these tragedies and tribulations
that were going to befall the
Muslims however these things are not
unnoticed to Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and we keep our faith in Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
that Allah will never
allow evil to
progress it may seem it's
becoming prominent and it may seem like
it is spreading and it may seem it
is taking hold but evil will always have
a temporary place in the creation of
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala and good will
always have a permanent place Allah
subhanahu wa
says that the end result will always be
to those who are righteous and dutiful
and Allah subh tells
us he tells
us subhanahu waala and do not allow your
resolve to become
weakened
and do not
regress
as do not allow your resolve to
become weakened do not regress in your
progress and do not
be sad in the sense that hopeless you do
not become
hopeless that is that regardless of how
things
seem you if you are True Believers will
always remain
above your
enemies and
you know
this this
situation it's almost like
they're trying to just get rid of
everybody just just rip the Band-Aid off
just forget to fall out rip off the
Band-Aid just murder senselessly
everybody and then deal with the Fallout
later it will just be forgotten
overlooked as is usual for this world
but what they failed to take into
account is the sight of Allah subhanahu
wa taala this will never just go
away Allah subhanahu wa
taala
punishes at the right time in the
appropriate
way and he subhanahu waala tells
us do not ever
think that Allah is unaware of what
wrongdoers and criminals engage
in he is merely
giving them time and he is merely
delaying their punishment to a day
when Humanity's eyes will be
unblinking out of sheer Terror and
horror and so we see this and
sometimes one fitna comes and it's
waves and it almost makes us forget
about the fitna that came before it and
the FNA that came before it but we don't
particularly we do we do not
view Palestinian
blood or Indian blood or African blood
or Asian blood or Western blood for that
matter as
being any different a Muslim is a
Muslim and a non-combatant non-muslim is
a non-combatant non-muslim they're still
a human
being so it's not that we are forgetting
what happens to our brothers and
sisters in the Communist lockdown
hellscape of China or the
genocide that took place and is
continuing to take place in rahunga the
crisis in
Syria our brothers and sisters in
Yemen and it's it's kind of depressing
to just list all of these things but
festine because of the Masjid AA because
this land this place is so vital and
pillar and a a place of of where Islam
is
anchored it becomes especially
heinous because now it is not just the
people who are being transgressed
against but also the holy sights of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
however it's important for us to
always remember
that the end
result that which matters will always be
for the
Believers Allah subhanahu
waala the prophet sallallah alaih
wasallam describes him to us
saying he says that
Allah continues
to give slack and give reproach to
the
oppressor until when he finally seizes
him he never releases him for eternity
and this is all part of the part of the
seduction of evil the
Seduction That these people think we can
just drop bombs on people's heads as
long as other human beings sanction it
then we get away with it that's not how
it works and the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam tells us
that he tells us
s that Muslim blood is so
sacred that if all of the people the
inhabitants of the heavens all of the
angels all of the creatures of the
heavens and all of the inhabitants of
the earth if they all
collaborated in
unjustly spilling the blood of a Muslim
Allah will place all of them in the fire
for doing
so and the prophet sallallah alai
wasam once spoke addressing the Kaa
and he
said has also been
narrated
that said this that the
sacredness of Muslim blood is even more
sacred than the Caba
itself and so this is
sometimes people they see these
things and in the moment it seems like
you know Allah subhah wa taal is
abandoning us or it's nothing of that
sort these things have to happen in
order for Progress to come and the
companions when they
saw when they saw the
Confederates collaborating in the battle
of the trenches in the battle of the
trench and it seemed absolutely hopeless
we have no way to defend ourselves
all of the Arab tribes have collaborated
even those who had previously aligned
themselves with us and allied with us
have gone against us they were coming in
from the east from the west from the
back from the front and they were
completely forsaken by all of humanity
when the companions saw this and when
the Hypocrites amongst them not amongst
the companions meaning the Hypocrites
that were in the presence of the
companions when they
were seeing this people
were tested but a good thing happened
what was that
thing pure good the good were
purified
and made even
better and the evil and the scum and the
the the the dirt and the
grime people were were set aside and
polarized from and separated from
those of true faith and so the
Hypocrites when they saw this they
started to doubt and said look what kind
of prophet is this if he was really a
prophet his God would not have forsaken
him in this way all of humanity has
collaborated against them they're going
to extinguish
them but the
companions when they saw things get to a
point where it's almost hopeless not
hopeless believer never becomes
hopeless but you know right there at the
edge the
companions understood that that is where
progress happens progress happens right
on the razor's
Edge and so when they got to that edge
Allah subhah waala tells us that they
said this is exactly what Allah and his
messenger promised would happen and told
us and foresaw it would happen and Allah
and his messenger are
true in their word and in
their and in and in their saying and
so what happened right after this right
after the best that was going to come
from the good came out and the worst
that was going to come from the bad came
out Allah subhah wa taala sent a wind
upon the Confederates totally ripped
them apart in one a few hours in the
evening and they all went back fleeing
they turned against each
other and those who forsake the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
his companions were exiled
and were eradicated this is this is
important for us to understand because
these things
happen and this is a test as well as it
is a place of
progress
that if it were not that
Allah
protected
some with others and another
interpretation of this verse is were it
not for Allah causing and allowing
conflict to happen on the earth the
earth would stagnate Humanity would
stagnate and wither
away but rather Allah subhah wa ta'ala
keeps this conflict this this
competition this right in order that
things and progress be had another thing
that's important for us to understand is
that we don't know what's exactly going
on anywhere right we depend on various
media to tell us what's happening
and I want you to take this into deep
consideration often
times
people we all of us all of our
generation the generation before us
once Television Satellite especially
internet became widespread became a
global thing the most important thing in
war is psychology
ology the most important thing is
propaganda and one of the cases of
propaganda that we never cease to see
throughout all of the conflicts is that
those
who have access and control that
propaganda
machine you to use it to make it
seem it's totally hopeless right
this country is just pummeling this
one and they're suffering no casualties
themselves they they themselves are are
fine right to try to dishearten their
enemy this is you know this
is conflict and War 101 right and so
Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
historians in the Quran and also in
history and even non-muslim
historians have a principle that they've
noticed throughout history and that
principle is that of the distribution of
power the distribution of power Allah
[Arabic recitation]
historically May before it may seem like
it from moment to moment but
historically to give all the power to
one people or one person and everyone
else is totally helpless this doesn't
happen right there is a distribution of
power and
so I say this because you know it's
being called Everything what it is
except what it is you know a conflict
a you know a dispute right it's two
neighbors fighting over some land now
this is more or less genocide exactly
by the name because the idea is to
eradicate a type of people but this
Roots back to our religion and Allah
subhanahu waala will never allow his
people to be totally extinguished it
can't happen it won't happen it never
will happen so it's important for us to
keep these things in our minds and to do
everything that we can of course
according to the leadership of our
of our respective leaders what I mean
by our leaders we have a community
we have those of us who are leaders and
we have to trust them and do
everything that we can within the
framework of what our Community is
able to do and continue to make Dua
inshallah and
you know the the the dawn the the
night is always darkest just before the
break of dawn continuing today
in authored
by we have arrived at the chapter
regarding the Miracles of the
prophet
[Silence]
for
so we are at the chapter regarding the
Mir mirales of the Prophet sallallah
alai wasallam it's important for us to
understand when it comes to the
Miracles of the Prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam these Miracles serve one
critical essential
purpose and that essential purpose of a
miracle of Allah subhanahu wa
taala is to either prove the validity of
a
prophet's
message or to
increase the faith of the followers of
that
message or
to
defend the followers of that message so
for
instance the flood
of right the flood
of this was
a right it was a miracle it was also a
sign of the validity of new
prophethood and it was also instilled
a deep rooted deep-seated un wavering
faith in the hearts of the followers of
no and likewise it was was used to
defend the followers
of so we will see these different types
of Miracles all put together
here
[Silence]
wasam
he tells us that the messenger of Allah
s. wasam was given very clear miracles
and
very
explicit Miracles and things that are
beyond the scope that that are superar
rational or super natural in their
case and that essentially is
what a is what is it referring to
it's referring to that which is
Supernatural meaning is be beyond what
nature is known for right changing the
Behavior or the
essential being of something this is
something that we know to be impossible
fire is hot water is fluid right but
Allah subhanahu wa taala causes these
Miracles and these
Miracles usually change the nature of
something according to the will of Allah
so for instance Allah subhanahu wa
taala parted the sea parted the sea for
M this is something that is beyond
nature this is something that was not
seen before or after the nature of water
is that it is fluid Allah subhanahu wa
turned it solid for that occasion
likewise fire fire is something that is
hot that's its nature but Allah
subhanahu waala made
it for ibraim he made it cool and
accommodating for ibraim which are the
two which is you know the apotheosis
of what fire is fire is unaccommodating
naturally at its Essence and is hot at
its Essence Allah subhah wa taala
changed its nature for ibraim for that
moment and this is something that no
amount of Technology can ever take
Humanity to this is something that
will never be able to be done and that
is the difference between it and you
know magic or Illusions right likewise
M The Magicians that threw down
their Andel they threw down their ropes
and
their
sticks and staffs
and made it appear and made it illusory
to the onlookers even mam himself that
these were giant serpents right but they
were not their nature was not changed
the way they were perceived was changed
but they were not
M his staff literally physically changed
this is something that no human being
can ever learn how to do these are rules
that only Allah subhanahu wa taala can
break these are laws that only the maker
of those laws may change at his
discretion subhanahu wa so the purpose
of
Miracles are as we mentioned
he
says and the Miracles of the Prophet
sallallah wasallam during his
lifetime they are in the thousands if
we were to enumerate them they are in
the
Thousand he says of the most well-known
of these
miracles
he tells us that the first and the crown
of all of these Miracles and the crown
of every miracle that any Prophet has
ever been given is that of the miracle
of the Quran it is the clear explicit
undeniable Miracle of Allah subhanahu wa
taala and the clear and explicit
evidence for the validity of the Prophet
Muhammad Sall alam's prophethood in
message and the Quran many many people
think that the Quran is a miracle in the
sense that its language is very Advanced
and its eloquence is unmatched and that
is one
dimension of the miracle of the Quran
that is not it's only
miraculous trait the
Quran is miraculous in more than that so
for instance if you think about the
Quran when we
translate the meanings of the Quran
right we can't you cannot absolutely
translate exactly precisely one language
to another it doesn't work that way but
when we translate some of the meanings
of the Quran a person who has studied
the Quran who is acquainted with its
many dimensions as Allah has described
it light upon
light can
see
the process of translating it for
instance from Arabic to English right
it's in my mind it's almost taking
a funnel you know a funnel that you
would use to pour liquids turning it
upside down and then
pouring the liquid in from the other end
most of it most of it is lost in that
translation
however still what remains of its core
meanings is so
powerful that somehow a person who live
1500 years later in a different land in
a different world might as well be from
a different Universe from the prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam and his
companions in a different language its
meanings are so
potent that a person will decide to
dedicate his or her life to the
disciplines found
therein of the
Quran and this person hasn't even has
not even experienced the Quran in its
original form only a few meanings of the
Quran we
say you know in the name of Allah the
most gracious most merciful different
translations you're just getting a
little dash of what that actually
says Scholars of Islam and the
scholars of and the
Quran you know
these words even though they're just
four words in a certain order their
meanings
are far beyond anything that could be
contained in one book or by one person
right it's divine essentially in its
nature and so somehow the
Quran is General
enough that it can apply to all of us as
human beings right a
person 1500 years ago in the desert in
the middle of
nowhere and a person all the way in the
west or the East 1500 years later in a
different
language somehow it is General enough to
apply to
all of
humanity but also specific
enough to be able toide guide people on
the individual level this is something
that is unmatched by any human being by
any of the creation of Allah subhanahu
waala so the incredible language and
eloquence of the Quran is not the only
dimension of its miraculousness or its
miraculous nature this is one but when
Allah subhah waala
says if you do not believe that this
Quran is from Allah then produce one
chapter it the shortest chapter of
the Quran is three
verses literally three verses two
lines
right
but the miraculousness is not limited to
just the eloquence of speech but also
what it contains what it
says human beings this is not how it is
it's WR to find a person who says
something that is of
substance and is also eloquent this is
rare people have to study to do these
things this is not something that a
regular person is usually born
with however you can see the impact that
the Quran had on the thoughts of people
a good way to measure that is to look
at What spark farse literature was
available
pre-islam and also the
Poetry The Poetry of the Arabs before
Islam and you compare that to the Poetry
just 50 years later or 40 years
later right so you have
the
the Quran was so
influential that it literally changed
the way people
thought and we know that because it
changed the way that they spoke
literature and when I say literature I'm
mostly referring to PO
poetry before the prophethood of
[Arabic recitation]
within 30 years or 40 years the Quran
was so influential that their poetry the
words they chose the way that they spoke
the ideals that they held were
completely changed you imagine changing
a culture that has been around for th
you know hundreds if not thousands of
years changing that in only 20 30 years
no
internet no you know no mail no
printing press people just learned these
words and repeated them and somehow this
book was so
influential that it was able to entirely
change the essence of how people
thought within a couple of decades this
on its own
articulates just how miraculous the
Quran is the Quran is described by Allah
subhah waala
as he tells us that which translates
to that the
Quran
no
falsehood or
error can come to it
before nor after in front of nor behind
it cannot be approached by
evil notice the wording here not that it
cannot be changed or influ it cannot be
approached by
falsehood and Allah subhanahu wa taala
tells us that the Quran is a revelation
sent down from one of incredible wisdom
and one who is incredibly
[Silence]
praiseworthy
for
tells us that this
Quran this Crown Jewel of the
Miracles of Allah subhanahu wa taala in
the
Earth
has
rendered the most
eloquent of speakers most eloquent of
writers
helpless in the most eloquent and at the
Pinnacle of the age of the Arab
eloquence so if you look through history
every language just anything of
humanity everything of earth right
anything on this Earth it has a
beginning and then it has a climax and
then it has a regression or it has a
right and and you can see this pattern
when it whether it's people individuals
or companies or neighborhoods
countries
races you know civilizations we all
have a beginning a highest point and
then a point where we digress from
there at the
Pinnacle of
AR the Arabic language at its height
when it was most profound when the Arabs
had finally you know finally reached
to a point where they are most
proficient in using this language the
Quran was
revealed
and there was an inability to respond to
it by Those whom were rendered
helpless in its
wake so we will continue along this next
week
insh